[Música]
he usado para esta presentación ese lema
de no aflojar porque realmente como
dicen con este lema hasta la muerte lo
respeta a uno
y cada día que yo me encuentro con
alguien en la calle el saludo es rocío
no aflojé y además un muy querido amigo
don yo bardo lizano el año pasado me lo
marcó lo tengo en mi oficina y eso es lo
que el recuerdo cada día el día de
mañana
el día de mañana voy a presentar en el
congreso el presupuesto 2020 y este
presupuesto en esencia lo que resume es
el fin del inicio y es el inicio
precisamente hacia la consolidación
fiscal todos los expertos lo esperan con
un gran sentimiento que es lo que va a
suceder efectivamente estamos con un
gobierno comprometido y el presupuesto
el día de mañana se los va a demostrar
yo tenía hoy la oportunidad de
presentarles las cifras porque lo iba a
llevar más temprano pero por esta
actividad lo pues puse a mañana así que
eso no será posible pero en estos
momentos en que hemos pasado la reforma
y que tenemos un ambiente realmente de
desconfianza de incertidumbre de lo que
está pasando en el mundo el pulmón del
amazonas' ardiendo el conflicto del
conflicto comercial los temas
tecnológicos y todo esto que estamos
viviendo me hace a mí realmente concluir
que si bien tenemos momentos de
incertidumbre que nos hubiera pasado si
nosotros no hubiésemos aprobado la
reforma fiscal no sólo tendríamos ese
ambiente negativo sino que posiblemente
nos hubiéramos retornado a lo que fue
este país en los 80 y que aquí entre
tanto milenio al poco lo recuerdo
esta época fue la época de la escasez
época de pobreza para el país época en
la cual los niveles de pobreza superaron
el 50 por ciento los niveles de
inflación son los que aparecían en la
primera parte del gráfico de rodrigo y
básicamente a eso es a lo que nos
hubiese conducido muy probablemente de
no haber tenido el país la valentía de
aprobar esa reforma y como fue que en el
2018 nosotros llegamos a donde estábamos
los 18 o 20 años de posponer decisiones
20 años o más 10 años por lo menos los
últimos 10 años o más de estar año con
año acumulando déficits un año en el
cual apareció el término de tasas de
interés obscenas que serían
pornográficas hoy más bien sin esta
reforma nos hubiera
probado un año en el cual tuvimos que
acudir a las letras del tesoro y trae
esa foto porque esa foto es precisamente
aquí en el club unión cuando el banco
central aprueba 26 años después de la
última vez inyectarle prácticamente 500
mil millones de colones al ministerio de
hacienda para que pudiera honrar las
obligaciones ustedes recordarán esos
días en los cuales el país prácticamente
iba a enfrentar la incapacidad de cubrir
los aguinaldos ustedes recordarán esos
días complicados en donde el ministerio
de hacienda pasaba viendo a ver qué era
lo que podía conseguir en el mercado
donde cada uno de esos días al que
enfrentaba
eran tasas de interés más altas y plazos
más cortos en esos días yo desarrolle
una profunda amistad con mi tesorero
porque me visitaba en la mañana y en la
tarde para que fuera a llamar a alguno
de los queridos amigos a ver si nos
ayudaban con recursos y fue realmente
una etapa muy convulsa y llamó ahora
porque creo que nosotros no debemos
olvidar esto que pasamos y cuando
empiezo yo a oír tanto nivel de
desconfianza que se ha generado en
realidad rescatamos al país rescatamos
al país del precipicio y vamos
absolutamente todos para el barranco
y dichosamente ya muy cerca de ese
barranco el país se unió y el país
decidió no aflojar y ese país que se
unió no fue sólo el poder ejecutivo
fueron los empresarios fueron las
cámaras la academia los diputados los
partidos políticos quienes entendieron
que el país no podía seguir destinando
esa decisión porque estaba prácticamente
en el barranco el tipo de cambio los
asustó las tasas de interés los asustó
tres meses de huelga por supuesto
asustaron y iphone del país decide no
aflojar y se une en ese último momento
con la aprobación de la reforma en la
cual la sala constitucional que como
mencionaba alan en dos oportunidades
anteriores se la había llevado
al suelo en esta oportunidad ayudo y hay
una frase en esa consulta de
constitucionalidad que realmente resume
la importancia de las finanzas públicas
la importancia de buenas finanzas
públicas que contribuyan a la
estabilidad que contribuyan al
crecimiento y que contribuyan al
bienestar y que unas finanzas que no
tienen esas características en nada nos
ayuda a ustedes que están en el mundo de
los negocios a los bancos que día a día
están intermediando entre unos y otros
realmente si eso no se hubiese logrado y
esa ende parece la frase que resume que
el equilibrio de las finanzas públicas
es ineludible para que no tengamos una
constitución fallida una constitución de
papel porque el resto de derechos y
garantías
no van a poder existir con unas finanzas
desequilibradas y en esto me parece que
hay que reconocer que el país decide no
aflojar que el país se une y el país
tiene que seguir
además unido para la fase que sigue esta
foto si a mí me encanta está la foto del
día en que la firma la ley de
fortalecimiento en las finanzas públicas
esto es efectivamente como yo llamo es
llegar al fin del inicio porque esto es
apenas el inicio de un largo camino que
el país todavía va a tener que recorrer
con una reforma que no debemos olvidar
es una reforma de muy alto calado tiene
los pocos ingresos de los que menciona
alan pero tiene un componente
es un componente muy importante y es
ponerle un estate quieto al gasto
corriente porque si hubiéramos hecho una
reforma con el 16 por ciento o más de
iva y no frenamos el gasto corriente y
no tenemos una regla fiscal a la vuelta
de tres o cuatro años estaríamos
buscando más impuestos es una reforma de
alto calado que no resuelve el 100% en
el corto plazo es una reforma que
requiere de muchísima disciplina
de que no aparezcan los rebeldes que se
quieren salir de la regla o de las
remuneraciones y todos tenemos que
apostar y apuntar a eso
logramos dos décadas
de discusión llegar a esa reforma hoy
día no sólo tenemos la reforma tenemos
un presupuesto que como ustedes verán
mañana refleja un punto de inflexión en
las finanzas públicas no estamos frente
a la solución cargamos a cuestas un
nivel del 60 por ciento de la deuda para
cerrar poco menos de 60 para cerrar este
año y no lo podemos ya realizar sólo de
manera orgánica con esta reforma se
requieren realmente cambios de carácter
estructural de los cuales habrá que
empezar a discutir pero al menos
logramos frenar la hemorragia y
recuperar la confianza y recuperar la
confianza en el mercado yo lo he vivido
durante los siguientes meses porque lo
primero que me di cuenta es que tenía
varias semanas de no ver al tesorero y
era que ella no tenía problemas
y ese fue el día que me di cuenta que
más viendo en la cosa se nos había
arreglado pero además logramos después
de la reforma la aprobación de los
créditos de apoyo presupuestario de la
corporación andina de fomento por 500
millones de dólares y adicionalmente
bueno del banco interamericano de
desarrollo por 350 millones de dólares y
la famosa ley de eurobonos por 1.500
millones de dólares perdimos la batalla
de que no fuera un año sino un programa
de financiamiento pero en un plazo muy
corto estará la ministra presentando en
el congreso la nuevamente esa ley
que hemos logrado adicionalmente en el
mes de julio es el mes donde se
consolida
o se implementa toda la reforma
entra en vigencia el impuesto al valor
agregado y las modificaciones de renta y
aquí el papel de alicia fue fundamental
para que realmente el ministerio de
hacienda no se atrasarán ni un día
porque la apuesta es que en el más
típico de nuestras formas de hacer las
cosas se iba a pedir una prueba
y el primero de julio entró el iba la
gente tuvo a disposición los formularios
los campeones del ministerio de hacienda
que así lo llamó yo lograron en seis
meses hacer todos los cambios normativos
reglamentos resoluciones que se pusieron
muchos de ellos y los más importantes a
conocimiento del público desde el mes de
enero o febrero para que se fueran
madurando
a través de lo que yo llamo el documento
martín que se me terminó finalmente
convertido en el reglamento
se aprobaron los eurobonos como lo
mencioné se firmó la ley de eurobonos al
día de hoy ya están contratados los
abogados y se inició esta semana la
contratación de los bancos y se le puso
efectivamente el freno al crecimiento de
los pluses salariales de más de 127 mil
funcionarios del banco central a
diferencia de la caja nosotros no
sabemos cómo el que parece que eso es lo
que les ha dificultado a ellos hacerlo y
en eso también hay que agradecer el
trabajo de alicia y se firmó también en
ese mes el crédito del banco
interamericano de desarrollo
estamos en la senda efectivamente hacia
la sostenibilidad hay muchísimo trabajo
hacia adelante en particular
el cumplimiento de la regla fiscal que
en este presupuesto es la primera
oportunidad en que aparece yo les puedo
asegurar y lo verán mañana no solo que
se cumple sino que se cumple de manera
holgada
no nos fuimos al techo realmente es un
presupuesto que muestra el fiel
compromiso de esta administración con la
reforma también nos enfrenta a una
cantidad importante de retos hoy día en
las minas del ministerio de hacienda ya
se una cantidad muy rica de información
que habrá que empezar con el trabajo del
equipo a usar de forma muchísimo más
inteligente para poder controlar otro de
los serios problemas que el país tiene
que son los problemas de la evasión
fiscal y donde la apuesta del impuesto
al valor agregado
partimos de la que nos va a ayudar a
mitigar pero esa riqueza de información
con la que hoy día cuenta el ministerio
es el siguiente paso para pasar a lo que
llamamos el modelo de los tercios que
hablábamos un día de estos y el modelo
de los tercios es que el ministerio de
hacienda con esa información va a
empezar a contactar a lo que llama don
alan los dolientes y esos dolientes
normalmente la respuesta de un tercio de
ellos es el pago inmediato se me había
olvidado
el otro tercio va a venir a decir sí
en los próximos días se lo pagó voy a
hacer un arreglo y el otro tercio es el
que vendrá a litigar con el ministerio
de hacienda para que efectivamente
podamos avanzar en ese camino yo
agradezco no solo que el país haya
llegado a eso sino a los más de 850 mil
contribuyentes que presentaron su
declaración del iva en el mes de julio y
que para el mes de agosto representó un
incremento de ese impuesto desde un 43
por ciento
esa es la comparación del iva con el
impuesto de ventas en muchísimas gracias
y yo los invito realmente a que no
aflojemos como país a quien no perdamos
la confianza este país ha tenido la
posibilidad aunque haya sido en el borde
del abismo de unirse
y rescatarlo y en las manos de ustedes y
de todos nosotros está el seguir
aprovechando de mejor manera las
oportunidades para que el bienestar de
la población que al fin del día es lo
que nos interesa puede hacerse una
realidad gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]